[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار السهلوها
تحذر بيلاروسيا من عواقب استقبال الاسلحه
نوويه رو
سيه
[موسيقى]
بين تمرير تعديلات الحصانه القضائيه او
انقسام عسكري يهدد امن اسرائيل
اريد ان نبني قوات مسلحه قوات ملتزمه من
الوصول للجيش الواحد هدفنا جميعا
رغم تباين التصريحات بينهما البرهان
ونائبه يتفقان على توحيد الجيش السوداني
وعدم اقحامه بالسياسه
مشرعون امريكيون يتواعدون تيك توك بالحظر
واخرون يطالبون بدليل قاطع على خطورتهم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان ابدا سابدا من هذا العاجل
الذي ورد الان نتنياهو يقيل وزير دفاع
اسرائيل من منصبه بسبب رفضه للتعديلات
القضائيه بحسب مراسل العربيه في في القدس
وطبعا يعني هذا هذه الاقاله تاتي بعد
التصريحات الاخيره لوزير الدفاع كما
تابعناها بالساعات المقبله الماضيه
وبالامس والتي اعلن فيها عن رفضه لكل
التعديلات مشروع التعديل القضائي الذي
طرحنا نتنياهو وهو ما انزل طبعا بانقسام
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه ساعود الى هذا
الملف خلال سياق التاسعه ولكن البدايه من
الملف الاوكراني والروسي توتر النووي جديد
اشعل فتيله الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
باعلانه ان بلاده ستنشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا الحليفه خطوه دفعت
بالغرب الى توحد في شجب الخطاب النووي
لبوتين اذ وصف الناتو التهديدات الروسيه
بالخطيره وغير المسؤوله واكد الناتو انه
متيقظ ويراقب تهديدات النوويه عن كثب اما
واشنطن التي تقود الناتو خففت من خطوره
خطاب بوتين مشدده انها لا تملك اي مؤشر
جدي من موسكو لاستخدام النووي حقا اما
الاتحاد الاوروبي فقد هدد بيلاروسيا حيث
قال بريل ان بيلاروسيا قد تعاقب لموافقتها
على نشره تلك الاسلحه على اراضيها
[موسيقى]
الحرب الاوكرانيه على شفا ان تتحول الى
مركز انطلاق معركه نوويه حقيقيه بين روسيا
من جهه وحلف شمال الاطلسي من جهه اخرى
[موسيقى]
وفي احدث سيناريوهات التصعيد انضمت
بيلاروسيا حليفه موسكو الى هذا الجدل الذي
بات يقلق العالم بعد موافقتها على استضافه
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه من روسيا
وبحلول يوليو سيكون لموسكو منشاه تخزين
كامله لاسلحه الرعب في هذا البلد المجاور
وفقا للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين تاتي
هذه الخطوه ردا على اعتزام المملكه
المتحده لتزويد كييف باسلحه تحتوي على
اليورانيوم المنظم وهو ما تعهدت موسكو
بالرد عليه
وفي خضم التهديدات المتصاعده بين موسكو
ولندن اكد بوتين ان بلاده لا تنتهكوا اي
التزامات دوليه بشان منع انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه رغم تجميد مشاركتها في معاهده نيو
ستارت التصريحات والاتهامات المتبادله
اعقبتها تحركات حيث قامت روسيا بالفعل
بنقل عشر طائرات قادره على حمل اسلحه
نوويه الى بيلاروسيا فيما يقول الخبراء
انها الرساله النوويه الاكثر وضوحا منذ
بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه
لكن على الرغم من كل التكهنات الذائعه حتى
الان فان الولايات المتحده القوه النوويه
العظمى الاخرى ردت بحذر على تصريح بوتين
حيث قال مسؤول كبير في اداره بايدن انه لا
توجد مؤشرات على ان موسكو تخطط لاستخدام
اسلحتها النوويه ما فتح المجال الاستنتاج
ان ما ستنشره روسيا لدى جارتها هي اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه مثل القنابل الصغيره
والرؤوس الحربيه محدوده المدى وطلقات
المدفعيه وكلها تستخدم لتحقيق مكاسب محدده
في ساحه المعركه وليست من نوع القنابل
الذريه التي تتسبب في القضاء على مدن
كامله بزرعها ونسلها
اذا ترسانه النوويه قادره على تدمير
العالم مرات عده مع مخزون يتضمن اكثر من
5500 راسا حربيا حقائق مخيفه اصلا زادها
رعبا تدشين روسيا منشئه لتخزين الاسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه هنا في بيلاروسيا على
الجبهه الشماليه تحديدا الغربيه من روسيا
لكن من الممسك والمتحكم باكبر مخزون في
العالم من الرؤوس النوويه بالتاكيد هو
بوتين صانع القرار النهائي الذي يحمل بين
يديه ما يسمى بالحقيبه النوويه في كل
الاوقات هناك حقيبتان متشابهتان يعتقد
بانهما بحوزه وزير الدفاع الحالي
ورئيس الاركان العامه الحالي
هذه الحقيقه او الحقيبه النوويه تشكل اداه
اتصال تربط بوتين بكبار ضباطه العسكريين
ومن ثم طبعا بالقوات الصاروخيه عبر شبكه
القياده والتحكم الالكترونيه الشديده
السريه كما هو معلوم غير ان بوتين بامكانه
تنشيط ما يسمى بنظام اليد الميته كملاذ
اخير وهي اجهزه الكمبيوتر التي تقرر ما
يسمى بيوم القيامه ان شعر بهجوم النووي
استراتيجي يواجه حينها ويرسل عبر هذه
الحقائب امر باطلاق مباشر الى قياده
الاركان العامه وطبعا وحدات القياده
الاحتياطيه التي تحمل رموزا نوويه لهذا
الاطلاق بعدها تتسلسل الاوامر بسرعه الى
انظمه الاتصالات المختلفه ووحدات القوه
الصاروخيه الاستراتيجيه لتطلق بعد ذلك على
الاعداء او المهاجمين المفترضين
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر رعد هذا الموضوع تنضم الي من
موسكو كاتيا طعم مراسله العربيه كاتشا
يعني عوده التهديد النووي من جديد ووضع
الحقيبه النوويه على الطاوله من جديد ما
اخر التحديثات والتصريحات من موسكو حول
موضوع نشر اسلحه نوويه في البلد روسيا
مرحبا ليال بالفعل الرئيس الروسي كان قد
تحدث عن ان روسيا ستقوم بانشاء مجمع
للاسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه في على الاراضي
البيلاروسيه طبعا كما تعلمين ليال ان
روسيا وبيلاروسيا هم دولتان تحالف وهما
طبعا كان قد وقع او كان قد اتفقا في العام
السابق على انشاء مجمع اقليمي للتعاون
العسكري بين البلدين وهذه الخطوه هي تاتي
خطوه جديده بعد ايضا تحدث الرئيس
البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو عن رغبه
بلاده بان تكون
تحصل على السلاح التكتيكي من روسيا كما
تحدث الرئيس الروسي
ان هذا لا يخالف طبعا معاهده عدم انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه لكن هو يقوم الان او يفعل
الان ما تفعله الولايات المتحده منذ عشر
سنوات بانها تقوم او كانت تنشر الاسلحه
النوويه ايضا تكتيكيه في جميع دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذه هي الخطوه كما تحدث الخبراء
ايضا هي تاتي بعد اعلان لندن نيتها بارسال
قذائف تحتوي على اليورانيوم وكما تحدثت
مرارا بيلاروسيا انها تقوم ايضا بتعزيز
قواتها على الحدود ردا على تحالف الناتو
الذي ينتشر ايضا من الجانب البولندي على
الحدود البيلاروسيه وايضا لرد اي تهديد قد
يحصل من الجانب الاوكراني
كاتل يعني بالمقابل اليوم هناك تهديدات
اوروبيه تحديدا
بعقوبات على بيلاروسيا بعزل بيلاروسيا
وطبعا هذا سيؤثر كثيرا على الداخل
بيلاروسيا كيف تقرا موسكو هذا الموضوع
وهل من جديد حوله
هي بيلاروسيا الان تتخذ هذه الخطوه او
روسيا تتخذ هذه الخطوه مع بيلاروسيا وليست
بجديده بالتعاون العسكري كما تحدث مرارا
الاتحاد قدرتان ان تتحمل او تواجها هذه
العقوبات الاقتصاديه بشراكات اقتصاديه
مشتركه كانت قد بداتها موسكو ومينسك في
وقت سابق طبعا ولكن هذه الخطوه كما تحدثت
ايضا انها تاتي على اثر تهديدات ايضا كانت
قد وجهت اليمين بسبب تواجد القوات حلف
الناتو على الاراضي
البولنديه وطبعا بسبب العلاقات المتينه
بين البلدين الرئيس البيلاروسي طبعا ذهب
الى هذه الخطوه
باتفاق مع الرئيس الروسي لان يتم انشاء
مجمع لقوات عسكريه مشتركه بين البلدين
تحسبا لوجود اي تهديد يهدد البلد مشترك
بشكل مشترك اما اقتصاديا كما ذكرت فان
لديهم لدى البلدين مشاريع مختلفه كما تحدث
مرارا رئيس البيلاروسي انها قادره ان تقف
امام العقوبات التي يمكن ان تفرض على
المسك ايضا شكرا لك كاتيا طعمي مراسله
العربيه حدثنا من موسكو
نبقى في اوكرانيا مشاهدينا هذه المره
ميدانيا حيث سيطره مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه
الروسيه على مصنع ازوف ازوم للمعادن في
الشمال مدينه بخموت وفقا لتقارير روسيه
واظهرت لقطات مصوره انتشار قوات فاجنر
باراضي مصنع ازوم في بخموت واذا تم
تاكيدها ستكون ردا على تقارير اوكرانيا
وبريطانيه بان القتال في بخموت تراجع بشكل
كبير في الاسبوع الاخير حسب ما قال
وبالتزامن مع ذلك نقلت صحيفه البريطانيه
عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيا قولها انها تخسر
ما بين 100 الى 200 جندي يوميا خلال
المعارك في مخلوط ووفقا للصحيفه فان
الخسائر الفادحه التي تكبدها الجانب
الاوكراني قد تجبر اكياف على مغادره بخموت
في نهايه المطاف بعد تسعه اشهر من القتال
العنيف بين الجانبين
ومع ارتفاع وتيره الحرب في الجبهه الشرقيه
بدا الاف المدنيين الاوكرانيين الانضمام
الى صفوف القوات بلادهم العسكريه تحديدا
الى قوات الحرس الهجومي وهي وحدات عسكريه
تابعه لوزاره الداخليه والهدف منها هو
الجمع بين خبره الجنود المتمرسين
والمتطوعين الجدد ويمكن لاي شخص اوكرانيا
التقدم بطلب الانتساب عبر الانترنت او
بشكل مباشر للانضمام الى الحرس الهجومي
الذي يتكون من سته الويه داخل الحرس
الوطني
وستقاتل هذه الالويه التابعه لوزاره
الداخليه الى جانب القوات المسلحه
النظاميه التابعه لوزاره الدفاع وسيكونون
طبعا جاهزين لخوض اولى معاركهم في مطلع
ابريل المقبل
[موسيقى]
اظهر مقطع مصور جنودا روسيا بوريجيا وهم
يسقطون طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه وبحسب
تقارير روسيه فان القوات الاوكرانيه
تستخدم طائرات كاميكازي المنخفضه التكلفه
لاستهداف المركبات المدرعه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
نشرت قناه الشؤون العسكريه الروسيه لقطات
الانفجار ضخم لقنبله القيصر بالاضافه الى
قنبله جويه تزن طنا ونصف الطن استخدمت في
اتجاه
[موسيقى]
حذر وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الاسبق سنجر
من حرب بارده ثانيه اكثر خطوره من الاولى
فقال كسنجر في مقابله مع صحيفه اسبانيه ان
الحرب البارده الجديده قد تبدا بين بكين
واشنطن كما اعرب عن اعتقاده بان كلا من
الدولتين تمتلكان موارد اقتصاديه متشابهه
لم تكن وهو ما لم تكن عليه الحال خلال
الحرب البارده الاولى واضاف كسنجر ان
القوتين الاقتصاديتين الضخمتين تحولتا في
الوقت الراهن الى خصمين معتبرا انه لا
يجوز انتظار ان تتحول الصين نحو الغرب
بحسب ما نقلت وكالات
[موسيقى]
السلطات الفرنسيه وضعت جانبا ما تمسكت به
لسنوات من اعتبارات اخلاقيه وعسكريه وقررت
احتضان مفهوم التسكع ولكن عسكريا فبعد
سنوات من التردد طائرات كميكازي بدون طيار
او المسيرات المتسكعه كما تلقب ستدخل
الجيش الفرنسي فوفقا لصحيفه نموض الفرنسيه
هذه الطائره ستكون متعدده المحركات ومجهزه
بالعديد من المراوح قادره على حمل ما يصل
الى 35 كيلو جراما من المتفجرات او
الذخيره طائرات كميكاز او الطائرات
الانتحاريه هي نوع من انظمه الاسلحه
الجويه لكن لماذا تعرف باسم الذخيره
المتسكعه لان هذه الطائرات تحوم لبعض
الوقت فوق منطقه يتم تحديدها على انها هدف
محتمل وتضرب فقط بمجرد التعرف على العدو
تتميز بصغر وسهوله اطلاقها طبعا لكن
الميزه الرئيسيه لهذه الطائرات تكمن
بصعوبه اكتشافها ورصدها وامكانيه اطلاقها
من مسافات بعيده فهذه الطائرات تشبه الى
حد كبير صواريخ كروس التي تضرب اهدافا على
بعد مئات الكيلومترات لكنها بديل ارخص
ثمنا واسهل بالتحكم وفي وقت تعود فيه طبعا
المسيرات العسكريه التقليديه الاكبر
والاسرع الى قواعدها بعد اسقاط ما تحمله
من صواريخ كميكازي تصطدم بهدفها لتنفجر
فيه فيما بعد
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الخلاف على التوقيت الصيفي يتسبب بازمه
جديده في لبنان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل التاسعه مشاهدينا
من اسرائيل حيث دفع وزير الدفاع بحكومه
نتنياهو دفع ودفع ثمن موقفه الذي اتخذه
برفضه التعديلات القضائيه التي يصر عليها
نتنياهو دفع بالاخير الى اقالته ما قد
يؤذن طبعا الوضع السياسي في اسرائيل
ويجعله اكثر تعقيدا فيما طلبت المحكمه
العليا الاسرائيليه من نتنياهو الرد على
اتهام منظمه حقوقيه له بازدراء المحكمه
هذا وكانت منظمه غير حقوقيه قدمت طلبا
للمحكمه العليا الاتهام نتنياهو بالذرائها
وذلك لادلائه بتصريحات حول التعديلات
القضائيه رغم تاكيد المحكمه ان ذلك يعد
تضاربا للمصالح وطلبت المحكمه نتنياهو
بالرد خلال اسبوع حين اكدت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه ان هذه التهمه قد تتسبب في سجن
نتنياهو او تغريمه
قبل ذلك حظيت دعوه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
لتعليق تعديلات مقترحه على نظام القضائي
في اسرائيل بالعديد من الاصوات الداعمه
طبعا من داخل حزب الليكود الذي يتزعمه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
وبالتالي قد تزيد هذه الدعوه من الضغوط
الحزبيه على نتانياهو وترفع احتمال تقلص
الاغلبيه البرلمانيه التي تحظى بها
الحكومه لكن مشاهدينا لماذا يصرنا تنياهو
على هذا التعديل بنظام القضائي سنعود
ونسرد القصه التي بدات قبل اسابيع فقط من
استلام نتنياهو للسلطه حين فصلت المحكمه
العليا حليف نتانياهو اريا درعي رئيس حزب
شاص المتشدد من منصبه وزيرا للداخليه
والصحه لادانته طبعا كما هو معلوم بقضايا
فساد وتهرب ضاربي سيما وان نتنياهو بذل
جهودا حثيثه لخلق ثغره قانونيه تلتف على
القانون الاسرائيلي يقول دون ان يتبوا
الملاحقون قضائيا المناصب الوزاريه الى ان
ذلك لم ينجح وفقا طبعا لاعلام اسرائيلي
الذي اضاف ان نتنياهو تعهد بمواصله السعي
لمواجهه القضاء التي من شانها ان تمنح
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي صلاحيات واسعه على
حساب القضاء طبعا وتشمل التعديلات
المقترحه الحد من المراقبه للتشريعات
الكنيست وسيطره الحكومه طبعا على تعينات
القضاه والغاء تدخل المحكمه العليا في
الاوامر التنفيذيه وبالتالي يمكن لهذه
التعديلات حال تم اقرارها ان تمهد الطريق
لعوده درع الى المناصب الوزاريه التي اقيل
منها ليس هذا فحسب بل ستساعد نتنياهو ايضا
في التخلص من قضايا الرشوه والاحتيال التي
تلاحقه وذلك بسبب ما تنطوي عليه من اضعاف
سلطات المدعي العام وكل هذا يعني طبعا منح
نتنياهو الحصانه الكامله من الم لاحقه
القانونيه الان ومستقبلا
[موسيقى]
بالتزامن مع هذه التطورات تستمر المظاهرات
في اسرائيل الاحتجاجا على قانون التعديلات
القضائيه في البلاد والتي اعلن عنها رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ليتجمع
المتظاهرون امام منزل وزير الزراعه ووزير
العدل وزير الاقتصاد الاسرائيليين
من المزيد من الخلافات والتصعيد داخل
الحكومه وداخل البلاد طبعا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القدس الدكتور
ماهر المصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه العبريه استاذ دكتور اسمح لي يعني
ان انوه لبعض العواجل التي وردت بعد اقاله
وزير الدفاع قاده الاحتجاجات الاسرائيليه
يقولون بان نتنياهو يتصرف كاديكتاتور اصيل
وزعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه لابيديا يقول
بان نتنياهو يهدد الامن القومي وائتلاف
الوحده الوطنيه الاسرائيليه يقول بان
نتنياهو مصمم على القاء اسرائيل في
الهاويه وطبعا الائتلاف يقول ايضا بان ما
يحدث اليوم من اقاله لوزير الدفاع هو
تحذير بسبب تحذيره من الخطر الامني حزب
العمل الاسرائيلي ايضا كان له تصريح ويقول
بان نتنياهو يشكل خطرا على امن البلاد وام
اسرائيل طبعا كل تصريحات تصب بمكان واحد
سابدا من هذا الموضوع من موضوع اقاله وزير
الدفاع بعد الحديث بالساعات الماضيه عن
انقسام داخل حكومات نتاني ما يمكن ان يشكل
ضغط كبير عليه لتمرير التعديل القضائي
ماذا يعني ذلك
تحياتي لك يا استاذي الكريم فيما يتعلق
باقات وزير الدفاع فيما يتعلق بايقات وزير
الدفاع في الواقع وزير الدفاع في اسرائيل
هو منصب سياسي وهو همزه الوصل بين الجيش
والحكومه ويجب عليه ان يعكس للحكومه
السوره التي تاتي اليهم من داخل الجيش ومن
داخل الاجهزه الاجهزه الاجهزه الجيش
وبالتالي لم يكن لديه خيار اخر هو ما فعله
وانا اعتقد انه كان الخيار الوحيد امامه
وبالتالي هو قام بدوره كوزير الدفاع
بمنتهى البساطه من ناحيه اخرى من ناحيه
اخرى العرف في اسرائيل كما هو الحال في اي
نظام نيابي هو انه
الوزير يجب ان يكون متضامن مع قرارات
الحكومه وبالتالي بناء على هذا العرف اقال
نتنياهو السيد جالنت وزير الدفاع ولكن هذا
لن يؤثر على مجرى الاحداث لانه السيد هو
من الممكن الفصله من الحكومه ولكن لا يمكن
فصله من الكنيست حيث انه عضو كنيسه عن حسب
الديكود وبطبيعه الحال سوف يصوت ضد مشاريع
القوانين التي تقدمها الحكومه ولن تؤثر
اقالته من الحكومه ومن منصبهم وكوازير
الدفاع على مجرى الامور على المستوى
النيابي طبعا هناك اشكاليه في
الموضوع الامني كما ذكر وكما ذكرتم على
لسان احزاب المعارضه في اسرائيل حيث ان
السيد هو العسكري الوحيد في معسكر نتنياهو
هو العسكري الوحيد
في السياق الحرب ضد الارهاب وكذلك
المواجهه الوشيكه مع النظام الايراني
والاحداث التي تشهدها منطقه لا شك في ان
هذا يشكل نوعا ما تهديد يعني بالساعات
الماضيه خرجت اصوات كثيره من اليمين
المتشددين من حزب اليهود يقولون لان وزير
الدفاع خضع لضغوط اليسار
الاسرائيلي وهناك ايضا انقسام داخل حزب
الليكود كيف يمكن ان يؤثر هذا الانقسام
الداخلي العمودي اذا صح التعبير على
التصويت على هذا المشروع في حال ذهب الى
الكنيسه خصوصا ان يعني هناك ترجيح بان هذا
الانقسام ممكن ان يؤثر عليه
اولا هو الازمه حاليا ليست ازمه سياسيه
الازمه اصبحت ازمه دستوريه حيث ان الحكومه
لم تعد في صدام مع اليسار او مع المعارضه
بل اصبحت في صدام مباشر مع الدوله مع
اجهزه الدوله مع القضاء والان مع الجيش
وكذلك مع الشرطه وبالتالي الازمه تاتي من
هذا الاشكاليه في مساله الشارع والتظاهرات
طبعا هذا الكلام على انه اليسار هو الذي
يمس
ك اليسار والمعارضه يساريه وطبعا يسار
اصبحت سبب في اسرائيل حيث انه حكومة
المتعاقبه عملت على شيطنه المفهوم في حين
انها المعارضه التي تتظاهر في الشارع هي
ليست المعارضه النيابيه التي بالمناسبه
تتكون كذلك من احزاب يمين حزب امل جديد
وحزب يميني اكثر من الليكود حزب اسرائيل
بيتنا وحزب يميني متشدد بل متطرف
عنه الانقسام حتى داخل معسكر اليمين حول
يعني هذه القضيه ما يتحدث عنه نتنياهو من
اعاده توازن للسلطات الموجود بين
التنفيذيه والتشريعيه والقضاء يرى هذا
المعسكر بانه تدمير يعني للنظام
الاسرائيلي ولكل من بنيت عليه اسرائيل منذ
عقود ما المخرج وهل ممكن ان يذهب نتنياهو
بهذا التحدي عبر تحديد موعد للتصويت عليه
في الواقع انا اعتقد انه المخرج هناك مخرج
واحد ووحيد وهو
تجميد الاجراءات والذهاب الى حوار مباشر
وجاد مع المعارضه في اطار المبادره التي
تقدم بها رئيس الدوله
الاسرائيلي يقول بان لا يحق لوزير الدفاع
ان يبقى في منصبه بعد خطابه بالامس وايضا
اعلام اسرائيلي عنتانياهو يقول بان وزير
الدفاع عمل ضد الحكومه والائتلاف الحاكم
اذا الانقسام ما زال يتوسع يعني بين بين
اركان النظام الاسرائيلي اليوم عوده اليك
تفضل صحيح صحيح هو ثمن خطاب الشعبوي
لا يحتوي على اي مضمون قانوني الذي تفضل
بها الوزير ولكن انا اريد هنا ان اقول انه
الازمه اخذت بعد اخر
حينما اعلنت الحكم وزير العدل سيد ليفين
وهو عراب
ما يسمى بحزمه الاصلاح القضائي حينما قال
بانه لو المحكمه العليا التي هي في
اسرائيل تلعب دور المحكمه الدستوريه
اقر
بدستوريه
المشروع القانون او مشاريع القوانين
بالاحرى نتحدث احد عشر مشروع قانون وليس
مشروع واحدا فسوف تمرر المشاريع القوانين
بالقوه حتى لو رفض الرئيس
يجب ان يوقع رئيس الدوله بعد ان ياخذ على
موافقه منها المحكمه المحكمه العليا
وبالتالي اعتقد انها هنا
تدخل تبدا الاشكاليه حيث انه
تبدا يكون هناك ابتعاد عن اطار عن اطار
الشرعيه وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه هذه
الاشكاليه لا اقول بانه لو مررت هذه
المشاريع بالقوه سوف تصبح دوله ديكتاتوريه
لا سمح الله الديمقراطيه لا احد يشكك في
نزاهه الانتخابات التي اتت بعد الائت
باسده الحكم لاحد يشكك فيه شرعيه الحكومه
الحاليه ولكن هذا سوف يضعف من الديمقراطيه
حيث
قبل قضائيه ومسلسل القضاء ويعني وهذا هو
الخوف اليوم لدى الجانب الاوروبي والجانب
الامريكي حتى يعني بعض الصحف الاسرائيليه
اليوم ذهبت لتعنون بان نتنياهو تعرض
لتوبيخ اوروبي وامريكي عقب كل ما يقوم به
اعلام اسرائيلي يقول بان نتنياهو استدعى
وزير الدفاع قبل اقالته وقال له بانه فقد
يعني
الثقه به وايضا التمار بن غفير ما زال
يعني يصرح ويقول بان قرار نتنياهو باقاله
وزير الدفاع صائب وادعمه في ذلك اتمام مع
يعني كل هذا الجناح الذي يرفض اي راي
مغاير خصوصا بموضوع يعني التعديل القضائي
كيف يمكن ان يدعم موقف نتنياهو
والراي الاخر كيف يمكن ان يضعف من موقف
نتنياهو باجازه لو سمحت
انا اعتقد انه
تعقيب وتعقيبا على ما قيل في في المقدمه
انا اعتقد انه نحن نتحدث هنا عن مشروع
قانون يهدف الى اخراج نتنياهو من مازقه
القضائي او انقاذ وزيره رئيس حزب شاسعي
ولكن الحديث هنا عن مشروع قديم مشروع
قديمه السيد ليفين هو 20 سنه يعمل على هذا
المشروع كذلك السيد سيمون وهو كذلك كتب
اكثر من كتاب في هذا الخصوص هناك مشروع
قديم لدى اليمين المتطرف ولدا شق من حزب
اليكود يعمل على اضعافه صوت القضائيه بل
اقصاء القضاء حيث انه بمشروعي هذا ينسف
مبدا الفصل بين السلطات ويعطي كل القوه
للحكومه التي سوف يكون بامكانها تمرير اي
مشروع قانون حتى لو كان يتعارض مع مشاريع
مع
سنبقى نعم سنبقى نتابع التصريحات
والانقسامات داخل معسكر نتنياهو المعسكر
الموائل يعني الاخر من اسرائيل شكرا لك
دكتور مصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه العبريه على وجودك معنا
[موسيقى]
الى لبنان حيث حتى على عقارب الساعه ينقسم
اللبنانيون فوصى ازمات اقتصاديه وسياسيه
استيقظ لبنان على توقيتين مختلفين اذ
اعتبر من اليوم وحتى العشرين من ابريل
المقبل سيعمل كل لبناني بالتوقيت الذي
يختاره او كما يختار حزبه او طائفته فيقرر
ان يبدا نهار اما بالتوقيت الشتوي او
الصيفي السجال بدا عندما طلب رئيس مجلس
النواب نبيه من رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال
نجيب ميقاتي تاخير العمل بتوقيت الصيفيه
العالمي مراعاه للصائمين خلال شهر رمضان
وهو ما لم يعجب احزاب ومكونات مسيحيه
اعترض طبعا على القرار ورفضت العمل به ما
تسبب ببعض الارباك خصوصا على قطاعات
الاتصالات والطيران شركه طيران الشرق
الاوسط عدلت مواعيد رحلات المغادره من
مطار رفيق الحرير الدولي تماشيا طبعا مع
التوقيت الرسمي لكن هذا لم يعجب وسائل
الاعلام لبنانيه التي دخلت على خط الخلاف
اذا اعلن عدد منها العمل وفق التوقيت
العالمي نظرا لتداعيات مخالفه هذا القرار
طبعا تقنيا وانعكاساته السلبيه بحسب تلك
المؤسسات ومن بينها وكاله الانباء
اللبنانيه
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من بيروت ناهد يوسف مراسله
العربيه للحديث اكثر عن هذا الموضوع طبعا
نهد يعني اشعر بالخجل ان نكون نناقش هكذا
موضوع بوقت لبنان يمر فيه بازمات اكبر
بكثير ما اخر التصريحات والانقسامات هناك
وعلى اي توقيت انت معنا الان
عفوا ليال لم اسمع السؤال بوضوح وكنت اقول
كنت اقول ما اخر التصريحات واخر
الانقسامات بهذا الموضوع خصوصا ان هناك
انقسام مذهبي وطائفي وبالشارع وعلى كل
السعوديه
نعم ليال يعني هو موضوع مضحك ومبكي يمكن
القول يعني اللبنانيون يعيشون في حاله
ضياع كليا وهذا الضياع اكثر سيتوضح يوم غد
لان اليوم هو عطله نهايه الاسبوع غدا تفتح
المصارف تفتح المدارس الجامعات وعندها
فعلا الضياع الحقيقي الذي سيعيشه
اللبنانيون هذا الموضوع الذي انتج فرزا
طائفيا جديدا ومناطقيا وعلى سبيل المثال
ليال وانا ايضا اعتذر يعني عن هذه اللغه
ولكن الان انا اقف وسط بيروت عند اذا في
خطيت خطوتان الى يمينه عندها في هذه
المنطقه سيكون التوقيت الساعه التاسعه
والنصف اما اذا توجهت الى يسار الى
المنطقه الاخرى يعني بين منطقه الجميزه
ومنطقه ساحه الشهداء في هذه المنطقه
الساعه 8:30 مساء يعني بين يفصل بينهما
شارع فقط هذه هذا الفصل الذي يعني تنقليه
كان يفصل الشرقيه والغربيه اليوم يفصل
الشتويه والصيفيه عن جد امر مضحك للغايه
بموازاه هذا هناك يعني حشد طائفي بطريقه
يعني بطريقه بشعه جدا وهناك محاوله
لاستخدام طبعا بموضوع استنهاض هذه
الطائفيه والعصبيه كيف اليوم يتم استخدامه
بالسياسه لانه طبعا هو ليس موضوع نكته فقط
نعم يعني هذا الموضوع استغل طائفيا
وسياسيا طائفيا يعني منذ يومين ومنذ صدر
هذا القرار بدا التجيج الطائفي على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي السياسيا بطبيعه الحال
تم استغلاله خصوصا وان من قام او من اتخذ
هذا القرار هما الرئيسان نبيه بري ونجيب
ميقاتي وذلك في جلسه دردشه البعض يقول
بانه لا يحق لهما وهو الامر ان القانوني
او الدستوري خصوصا وانا هذا هكذا قرار يجب
ان يتخذ بجلسه مجلس وزراء يعني هناك من
يدعوا
يدعو بري وميقات الى العوده عن هذا الخطا
وان يتم اتخاذ هكذا قرار فقط بموافقه مجلس
الوزراء البعض الاخر الاحزاب الاخرى
وخصوصا رئيس التيار الوطني الحر جبران
باسير الذي منذ اللحظه الاولى بدا
باستغلال هذا الموضوع سياسيا وطائفيا
والتجييش على هذا الموضوع يعني حتى اليوم
كانت هناك له كلمه وصف من بقي على التوقيت
الشتوي اي توقيت كما يصفه اللبنانيون
بالرجعيين والمتخلفين يعني هذا الموضوع
فعلا يتم استغلاله في السياسه من اجل
التجييش السياسي والطائفي كل
لمصلحته السياسيه ولكن اللبنانيون يعني هم
من يعانون من تداعيات هذه الازمه كنا
نتحدث الى عدد كبير من المواطنين مثلا على
سبيل المثال عدد كبير من المواطنين نباتهم
من يوصلون اولادهم الى المدارس يعني لانهم
لم يعودوا يستطيعون الدفع تكلفه باص
المدرسه اليوم
وظائفهم مثلا بقيت على التوقيت الشتوي اما
المدارس فهي على التوقيت الصيفي لذلك هناك
ليست لم تعد هناك قدره على ايصال اولادهم
الى المدارس لان التوقيت اشغالهم قبل
مواعيد مدارسهم هذا مع العلم بان ليست كل
المدارس التزمت اليوم وزير التربيه اصدر
بيانا اعلن بالتزام كل المدارس بالتوقيت
الصيفي الا ان عدد كبير من المدارس وخصوصا
المدارس الاسلاميه انجاز التعبير بقيت او
اعلنت بانها ستبقى على التوقيت الشتوي
يعني اليوم يمكن القول هناك ليس فقط توقيت
صيفي او توقيت شتوي يمكن القول ان هناك
توقيت اسلامي وتوقيت مسيحي وتوقيت بري او
توقيت عالمي يعني هذه هي اللغه التي باتا
يتحدث فيها اللبناني للاسف للاسف ناهد
شكرا لك ناهد يوسف مراسلات العربيه حدثتنا
من بيروت
[موسيقى]
انطلقت في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
اليوم اعمال ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
بحضور العسكريين والمدنيين الموقعين على
الاتفاق الايطالي والشركاء الدوليين والتي
تاتي ضمن قضايا المرحله النهائيه للعمليه
السياسيه في البلاد وقال رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان خلال
الجلسه الافتتاحيه ان القوات المسلحه لن
تقف حجره عثره في سبيل اصلاح الدوله
السودانيه ونوه طبعا الى ان الاصلاح
الامنيه والعسكري عمليه طويله ومعقده ولا
يمكن تجاوزها بسهوله ويسر مضيفا انه يجب
ابعاد الجيش عن السياسه
اخر ورش العمليه السياسيه والاولى في
تاريخ السودان ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري هي العنوان الابرز في خواتيم
العمليه السياسيه اكثر من 250 مشاركا
ممثلين من كافه الاجهزه النظاميه وقوى
مدنيه اما قاده الجيش الذين شاركوا في
الورشه دون اعلان مسبق فقد وضعوا النقاط
على الحروف هذه المشاركه التي اريد بها
استغلال القوات المسلحه لدعم جهات سياسيه
او لفرض دكتاتوريات او لمسانده حكومات
شموليه نريد لهذا الامر ان يتوقف نريد ان
نبني قوات مسلحه قوات ملتزمه
هنا تدور نقاشات حول امكانيه تنفيذ خروج
القوات المسلحه والقوه النظاميه الاخرى من
الحياه السياسيه بالاضافه الى تنقيه
المؤسسه العسكريه من عناصر النظام السابق
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع والحركات المسلحه
في الجيش عمليه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
ليست مهمه سهله ليست مهمه سهله لكنها
ضروريه كجزء من الاصلاح من اصلاح الدوله
ولذلك فان الوصول للجيش الواحد هدفنا
جميعا
ونسير فيه بقناعه وفقا للمسائل الفنيه
المتفق عليها تظل الجداول الزمنيه للدمج
هي العقبه التي تتصارع حولها الاطراف دون
الوصول اليها لكن رغبه اطراف العمليه
السياسيه قد تسهل من صعوبه المهمه
الورشه تحت الاصلاح الامني العسكري في
اربع يوم التاليه اللي هو اول يوم ليله 26
لحد يوم 29 هي المعايير
والمفاهيم المطلوبه للعمليات الاصلاح
الامني في الاجهزه الامنيه المختلفه بعد
فتره من السيال وطول انتظار التامت هذه
الورشه لكن يبقى السؤال مطروحا هل سينجح
المؤتمرون في وضع خطه محكمه لجيش قومي
واحد يلبي تطلعات السودانيين الطامحين
للحريه والسلام والعداله سالم الهاشمي
العربيه الخرطوم
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
نحو ثلاثه ملايين تصريح للعمره في رمضان
حتى الان وتوافد كبير على المسجد الحرام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ارسل الجمهوريون في مجلس
النواب الامريكيه رساله الى مدعي عامه
لتزويدهم بمعلومات حول لائحه الاتهامات
المحتمله تجاه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بشان احتماليه دفعه اموالا لنجمه اباحيه
وفق صحيفه
من اعضاء المجلس الجمهوريين قد وضحوا في
رسالتهم ان الاتهام موجه للرئيس السابق
والمنتخب من قبل الحزب والذي يحتمل اعاده
انتخابه وان هذا الاتهام ينطوي على مصالح
فيدراليه ويقوض عمل المدعين العامين
المتفلين
وقبل ايام فقط حتى انصاره على التظاهر
مغذيا ومعديا ذلك بامكانيه اعتقاله لكن
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب يبدو اكثر
ارتياحا اليوم طبعا حيث رجح ترامب اسقاط
المدعي العام في منهات القضيه المرفوعه
ضده نظرا الى عدم امتلاكه اي شيء ضده وفق
تعبيره طبعا واستخدم الرئيس الامريكي
السابق اول حشد كبير في حملته للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله لينصف نفسه باكثر الرجال
براءه في التاريخ الامريكي ويصف القاضيه
بالفارغه والمزوره هذا واكد ان تحقيقات
الجنائيه معه بشان شراء صمت ممثله اباحيه
كانت سلوك ادعاء وفقه صحيفه ديليت الاجراف
مكتب المدعي العام من جهه رفض التعليق على
هذه التصريحات علما بان هيئه المحلفين
ستستانف عملها طبعا يوم غد وقد يتم توجيه
الاتهام الى ترامب الاسبوع المقبل
تحت شمس ولايه تكساس الدافئه يقود ترامب
حملته الانتخابيه بعيدا عن القضبان واروقه
المحاكم بعد ان اكد مسبقا نيه المحكمه في
اعتقاله واغراقه بالتهم يواجه ترامب اليوم
تهمه الحريه بعد ان ذهب بعيدا باثارته
الفوضى ولعبه على عاطفه الانصار يقول
الديمقراطي بعيدا عن محكمه منهتا نجح
الرئيس السابق في جمع الالاف من انصاره
لكن ترامب المتهم تقع على هويه ترومبا
المترشح
مدعي نيويورك العام مدفوعا بتعليمات
تلقاها من وزير العدل في واشنطن قام
بالتحقيق حول قضيه لا تعد جريمه ولا حتى
مخالفه
وهو يغادر تكساس اكد ان محكمه نيويورك
بصدد اسقاط القضيه اعلانات كاذبه سوء
استخدام اموال الحمله الانتخابيه عشرات
القضايا المماثله ان لم تكن
قد تعود الى الواجهه مع ارتفاع حمى
الانتخابات لكن ترامب يولي اهميه الطريق
العوده الى البيت الابيض اكثر من بناء
برنامج انتخابي لم يتغير منذ سنوات
انه امر فريد حير خبراء القانون لقد
راقبوا احد عشر مليون صفحه من المستندات
ولم يجدوا شيئا ضدي لقد انشات شركه رائعه
ربما يجعلني هذا الرجل الاكثر براءه في
تاريخ بلدنا
القضاء الامريكي تحول الى اهم خصم يعيق
عوده
وفي انتظار ذلك يتسلح المتهم بانصاره
وقبليتهم لغزو الشوارع من اجل ضمان حريه
ترامب المترشح
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الملف ينضم اليه من
واشنطن مراسل العربيه اخر التطورات حول
الملف القضائي الترامب معك تفضل
غدا ربما يكون يوم اخر مهمه في ما يحدث في
نيويورك الاسبوع المقبل ايضا يجب ان ننظر
الى ان مساعدين كبار للرئيس السابق عملوا
معه في البيت الابيض سوف يمثلون امام
المحققين في قضيه سته يناير اي الهجوم على
مبنى الكونغرس الامريكي هناك قضيه ثالثه
في جورجيا ومن المنتظر ايضا خلال الايام
المقبله ان نسمع من ولايه جورجيا ان كانوا
سوف يوجهون اتهامات للرئيس الامريكي
الرئيس الامريكي السابق بدون شك انه تمكن
من خلال كل ذلك ان يصور نفسه على انه
الشخص الذي يلاحقه الديمقراطيون ويستعملون
الاداره الامريكيه والقضاء
ليمنعوا وصوله مره ثانيه الى البيت الابيض
وهذا ما يعطيه شعبيه كبيره وحماس في صفوف
المؤيدين له من الحزب الجمهوري
ايضا بالساعات الماضيه اختار مكان له
رمزيه يعني تاريخيه عند الامريكيين بسبب
ما يحمل من حدث لليمين المتطرف هناك
بالسنوات الماضيه الرسائل التي وجهها من
هناك ومن هذه المنطقه بالذات كيف يعني
يقراها الداخل الامريكي
عندما اعلنت حمله ترامب انه سوف يتوجه الى
المطار في مدينه ويكو تم ربط هذا الحدث
الانتخابي بما حدث منذ ثلاثين عاما مع
الطائفه الداوديه قرب مدينه ويكو اعتقد لو
سمحت لي القول ان هذا التوجه كان فيه
الكثير من الظلم للحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس
السابق وايضا لمدينه يويكو التي اعرفها هي
مدينه صغيره
باغلبيتها هي من الفقراء والذين يصوتون
لمصلحه الديمقراطيين هناك جامعه معروفه
جدا هي جامعه بيلر وليس هناك اي رابط بين
هذه المدينه والطائفه الداوديه سوى ان هذه
الطائفه جاءت وسكنت في مجمع سكني قريب من
هذه المدينه حمله ترامب اكدت انه اختار
هذا المكان بالذات لانه يبعد بمسافه
ساعتين فقط عن اربع مدن كبيره في ولايه
تكساس وهي دالاس واوستن وسننتونيو وهيوصل
وهذا بالفعل ما حدث شكرا
خسائر ماديه وبشريه كبيره تسبب بها اعصار
مدمر في ولايه الامريكيه ما دفع بالرئيس
جو بايدن الى اعلان حاله طوارئ في الولايه
الواقعه جنوب الولايات المتحده وحتى الان
لقي ملا يقل عن 25 شخصا مصرعهم اصيب
العشرات بينهم نساء واطفال بدورها تواصل
فرق الانقاذ عمليات البحث والانقاذ على
اثر هذا الاعصار القوي وهذا ودمر الاعصار
ايضا العديد من القرى والمناطق الريفيه
وتسبب في سقوط الاشجار وقطع خطوط الطاقه
فيما تستعد عده ولايات جنوبيه في الولايات
المتحده لاحتمال انتقال الاعصار اليها
خلال طبعا الساعات المقبله
[موسيقى]
ايضا اكد رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كاظم
الصين بمقطورها الوصول بسهوله لبيانات
مستخدمي تيك توك في الولايات المتحده وهو
ما يستدعي المضي في اصدار تشريع يعالج ما
وصفه بمخاوف الامن القومي واضاف ماكارسي
ان الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك
لم يكن صادقا اثناء مثوله امام لجنه
الطاقه والتجاره بمجلس النواب الامريكي
وهو ما يستدعي حمايه بيانات الامريكيين
عبر التشريع الجديد الذي يعده مجلس النواب
تتواصل مساعي بعض المشرعين في الولايات
المتحده الهادفه لحظر وتقييد تطبيق تيك
توك بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن القومي
واتهامات بالتجسس لصالح الصين هذه المره
يمضي مجلس النواب الامريكي قدما في اصدار
تشريع لحمايه المواطنين من المنصات
الرقميه الصينيه حيث باتت معالجه مخاوف
الامن القومي اولويه وفق تصريحات رئيس
المجلس كيفن ماكرثي ماكرثي قال ان تصريحات
مدير مجلس اداره تطبيق تيك توك امام
الكونجرس تضمنت معلومات خاطئه وتضليلا
بينما طالب مشرعون معارضون للحظر الحكومه
بايجاد دليل اكثر اقناعا على ان التيك توك
يمثل تهديدا للامن القومي غير ان التزايد
شعبيه تيك توك في امريكا يمكن ان يساهم في
خساره الرئيس بايدن للتاييد الشعبي وخلق
معارضه داخليه لدى جيل
فالشركه لديها الان اكثر من 150 مليون
مستخدم في الولايات المتحده اي ما يقرب من
نصف عدد السكان في حين ان 5 ملايين شركه
امريكيه تستخدم تطبيق تيك توك للوصول الى
عملائها يذكر ان مساعي الحظر في عهد اداره
الرئيس ترامب لم ترى النور حيث خسر سلسله
من الاحكام القضائيه في عام 2020 عندما
سعى الى حظر تيك توك وتطبيق اخر مملوك
للصين
[موسيقى]
في رابع ايام شهر رمضان بلغ عدد التصاريح
الصادره عن تطبيق عن طريق تطبيقين نسك
وتوكلنا لاداء العمره اكثر من مليونين
وثمانمائه الف تصريح فيما يستمر توافد
المعتمرين والزوار على مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي بجده حيث عملت اداره المطار
على تحويل المزيد من رحلات شركات الطيران
الاجنبيه المنتظمه ذات الحموله العاليه من
ركاب العمره من الصاله الشماليه الى مجمع
صلاه الحج والعمره وذلك وفق الطاقه
الاستيعابيه كما يستمر المعتمرون في
القدوم عبر الرحلات الدوليه والداخليه في
المطار
هذا وافقت مشاهدينا اعداد مستخدمي حافلات
مكه 37 مليون مستخدم منذ بدايه انطلاق
المشروع ويعمل مشروع على خدمه المعتمرين
والزوار والسكان من خلال محطاته المختلفه
في مكه المكرمه علما بان حافلات مكه تغطي
مساحات واسعه من خلال 13 مسارا تمر فيها
اكثر من
438 محطه في مختلف احياء مكه المكرمه
لنقل الصوره من هنا ينضم الينا من مكه
المكرمه عبد الواحد الحميد مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد كيف هي الصوره من هناك تفضل
اهلا وسهلا بك نعم في طبعا بشكل مستمر
ياتي المعتمرون الى هذه المحطه من مداخل
مكه المكرمه المختلفه للوصول الى المسجد
الحرام هذه المحطه كما تشاهدون في الصوره
المكتظه بالحافلات التي تنقل المعتمرين
والزوار وحتى السكان الذين يعملون في
اماكن مختلفه في المسجد الحرام تنقلهم
بشكل مستمر الى المسجد الحرام من هذه
المحطه وهكذا الحال في محطات اخرى حيث
يستمر نقل المعتمرين بشكل مستمر حيث ياتي
المعتمرون من مداخل مكه المكرمه المختلفه
لي طبعا
وايقاف سياراتهم في خارج حدود مكه المكرمه
واستخدام النقل العام من خلال هذه
الحافلات
المجهزه لنقلهم الى المسجد الحرام في مسار
اخر نتحدث عن حافلات مكه التي تغطي مساحه
شاسعه من مكه المكرمه نتحدث عن عشره مسارا
يغطي 560 كيلو متر اكثر من 400 حافله تمر
من خلال
488 محطه هذه الحافلات تجاوزت اكثر من 37
مليون مستخدم منذ اطلاقها وحتى نهايه شهر
فبراير هذا العدد الكبير من المستخدمين
الذين يعني تنقلوا من خلال هذه المحطات
التي تشكل محاور رئيسيه في مختلف الشوارع
والمناطق والاحياء في مكه المكرمه حيث
استطاعوا ان يتنقلوا بكل يسر وسهوله وفي
اوقات قياسيه بحكم ان هذه المحطات وهذه
الحافلات تعمل على مدار الساعه من خلال
المسارات التي تكون بشكل مستمر تستقبل
الزوار وكذلك المعتمرين
في ايصالهم الى المسجد الحرام هذه
الحافلات في هذه المحطه تقوم بنقل
المعتمرين الذين قدموا الى المسجد الحرام
فيما يتعلق بالمعتمرين القادمين من من
مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده هم ياتون الى
مكه من خلال طرق عده نتحدث اما عن طريق
اولا الحافلات التي خصصت لنقل هؤلاء
المعتمرين بشكل مجاني او حتى عن طريق
سيارات الاجره او عن طريق قطار الحرمين
الذي ينقل هؤلاء المعتمرين من خلال
الرحلات يعني موجوده خلال كل ساعه هناك
رحله من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الى محطه
القطار في حي الرصيفه في مكه المكرمه حيث
يستخدم المعتمرون وسائل النقل هذه للوصول
الى المسجد الحرام
عبد الواحد على كل حال يعني سنبقى نتابع
معك ومع الزملاء في مكه نقل الصوره من
هناك طيله شهر رمضان المبارك شكرا لك من
مكه المكرمه عبد الواحد الحميد مراسل
العربيه على هذه الرساله
خدام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
اسلحه نوويه روسيه
لوقوفه ضد التعديلات القضائيه نتنياهو
يعاقب وزير دفاعه ويقيله من منصبه
اريد ان نبني قوات مسلحه قوات ملتزمه من
الوصول للجيش الواحد هدفنا جميعا
البرهان ونائبه يتفقان على توحيد الجيش
السوداني وعدم اقحامه بالسياسه
مشرعون امريكيون يتوعدون تيك توك بالحظر
واخرون يطالبون بديل قاطع على خطورته او
بدليل قاطع على خطورته
التاسع انتهت مشاهدينا لكن اخبار العربيه
طبعا مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360
والزميله راويه راويه اهلا بعودتك شكرا يا
ليان شكرا جزيلا لك
سنتابع الملفات التي فتحتيها اقاله وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي جالنت وايضا التهديدات
الروسيه النوويه المتكرره تابعي تفضل